l'agenda vous présente cette semaine des
oeuvres tout en couleurs pour un artiste
haut en couleurs il s'agit de pierre
rebichon et des le nom le ton est donné
exposition s'appelle ma vie d'ange à la
galerie du gard voici deux carottes
ou encore troupeau de big sur un puits
en vue
et aussi des cartes bleues qu'on ne s'y
trompe pas il s'agit bien d'une
exposition et non pas d'un spectacle
comique mais l'humour et le moteur de ce
peintre de la région de millau en
aveyron
des pharisiens disait pas mieux lisez
milo très souvent milo ont suivi nos
2000 aucun alors j'ai fait donc le
viaduc de millau où j'ai cassé un bras
on se pose encore des questions sur ce
champion cycliste qui a gagner gagner
gagner gagner gagner ça devrait c'est la
question que je pose que thomas cotty
ancien graphiste pierre robichaud a
toujours été blagueur comme lorsqu'il
travaillait dans la publicité
exemple avec cette caricature de jeanne
d'arc en 1979 la mairie d'orléans
l'avait fait retirer il était le seul
dans ce style
tous les clients agences de pub avec qui
j'ai pu travailler il n'avait pas le
sens de l'humour comme l'abbé pierre ça
c'est clair
mais sous ses airs rigolard pierre
robichaud est un homme en colère
il peint la finance folle qui engendre
entre autres fermetures d'usinés
pollution mais toujours avec humour et
optimisme je préfère me marrer vous
présenter la réalité et présenter la
réalité ça serait une table
importe quoi je veux dire je préfère
faire des allégories disons nous
encourager les gens encourus
mais ce que j'aime bien dans mes
expositions c'est que les gens sortent
les deux sourires sorte heureux petit
jeu de mot apprécier et à méditer
jusqu'au 20 juin prochain toujours au
chapitre des expositions
voici la mosaïque de photos à chartres
la collégiale saint-andré et verges 350
clichés amateurs jusqu'au jeudi 4 juin
musique avec un nouveau jeu de mots le
vous dans l'indre sera rebaptisé le
roots le temps d'un week-end les 5 et 6
juin au son des musiques reggae électro
à suivre le groupe fayat ca veut du loir
et cher qui s'y produira le 5
dans un tout autre style c'est la star
du rap français cette année
black m du groupe sexion d'assaut sera
au zénith d'orléans ce jeudi
et encore une exposition pour finir le
peintre philippe charpentier présente
ses oeuvres à la galerie capazza dans le
cher les tableaux à voir jusqu'au 5
juillet prochain
l'agenda c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
la semaine prochaine nous parlerons de
musique et plus exactement du groupe les
burning est originaire d'orléans